كنت أبًا ، غيرت
التزامك تجاه المستخدمين يمكن أن يغير
التزامك
بمستقبلهم وما يبدو عليه Facebook لطيفًا بشكل جيد
أعتقد أن وجود أطفال يتغير كثيرًا مثل
ما كنت أعرفه جيدًا كنت أعتقد أن
الشيء الأكثر أهمية بالنسبة لي  إلى
حد بعيد ، كنت تعرف أن لدي أكبر
تأثير إيجابي في جميع أنحاء العالم يمكنني
القيام به ، والآن أنت تعلم أنني مهتم حقًا
ببناء شيء
ستكبر به فتياتي ويفخر
بي ، وأعني أن هذا هو
النوع اللطيف  من فلسفتي التوجيهية في هذه
المرحلة هو أنك تعرف ، وأنت تعلم
، تعال واعمل على الكثير من الأشياء الصعبة
خلال النهار وأعود إلى المنزل وأسأل فقط هل
ستفخر فتياتي بما فعلته اليوم
لأننا نجلس هنا خلال إحدى  أصعب
اللحظات في Facebook وربما
أقول لك لحظة صعبة حقًا بالنسبة لك
شخصيًا ،
هل تشعر وكأنك تفعل ذلك
، أعتقد أن هذا الجزء مما يجعل الحياة
ممتعة مثل التحديات
التي تواجهها وأنا ممتن جدًا  الذي - التي
نيابة عن هذا المجتمع ،
أعمل على حل بعض أهم
المشكلات في العالم ونحن
ملتزمون بتنفيذ هذا الأمر بالشكل الصحيح للناس